la poursuite du délinquant est
interrompue en raison de la note 89 qui
encadrent ce type d'intervention selon
ses instructions les poursuites des
véhicules ne doivent être liés qu'à des
faits d'une grande gravité comme la
fuite ou l'évasion d'un individu
dangereux ou les auteurs de crimes de
sang pour les autres situations moins
graves il ne doit pas y avoir de prise
en charge systématique les syndicats de
police dénoncent une forme d'impunité
les syndicats réclament l'aménagement de
cette note les délinquants eux ne sont
pas pour autant exemptés de sanctions
puisque l'enquête peut permettre leur
identification et leur interpellation
ultérieure allez on va écouter Gilles
[Rires]
si on continue comme ça ça ne marchera
pas donc moi je suis pour réarmer
correctement les policiers qui puissent
utiliser leur arme je suis pour mettre
des caméras dans la rue et je suis pour
les courses poursuites aussi voilà
ça devient un gag que j'arrête d'écrire
des trucs drôles tu vois les deux flics
dans la bagnole il y a un mec qui vient
de faire un forfait il s'échappe le dit
non ralenti
ralentir
on va écouter Gilles Verdez le génie
c'est pas ça c'est pas ça le débat du
tout c'est trop dangereux les courses
poursuites c'est dangereux pour la
police c'est dangereux pour les filles
on s'en fout et c'est dangereux pour des
tas de gens au bord de la route
aujourd'hui les fuyards ils ont des
voitures surpuissantes il peut y avoir
des drames et puis les policiers qui les
poursuivent ils prennent des risques
donc il faut arrêter ça et cette note
Cyril elle est parfaite parce que elle
n'interdit pas les courses poursuites en
cas de crime de sang ou d'évasion ou de
fuite très donc il faut arrêter comme ça
les courses poursuites ou les policiers
risquent ça écraser des gens et de
mourir eux-mêmes protégeons les
policiers
oui avec plaisir ce qui m'a dit dans ce
cas ce qui m'a choqué dans ce cas ici il
faut protéger les fuyards encore une
fois on veut
tu veux tout le temps protéger les
délinquants
parce qu'on vit dans un pays on n'a pas
assez peur de l'autorité on n'a pas
assez peur de la police et par les
Guilers les policiers faire des courses
poursuites et pas que quand c'est
extrêmement grave et pardon mais
pourquoi les courses poursuites existent
parce qu'il y a des délinquants c'est
aussi de manière de les dissuader et là
on veut encore protéger les délinquants
protège pas les bélards quand on protège
les riverains et on protège les
policiers c'est ça qu'on fait en fait
c'est pas qu'on protège
la note elle est extrêmement précise
elle dit vous avez le droit d'y aller
sauf il compose surtout quand ce sont
des délits de fuite des crimes de sang
évasion d'une personne extrêmement
dangereuse donc dans des cas extrêmement
précis ou ou justement nous sommes tous
en danger mais quand il y a pas de
dangereux
je vais prendre l'exemple du du de tous
les gens qui sont venus ici qui sont
fait voler leur voiture qui sont fait
voler des choses dans leur magasin donc
ça veut dire que là là tu laisses se
barrer non mais c'est ça c'est la note
puisque vous êtes d'accord avec ça ou
pas Géraldine ah non moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord parce que en fait la
délinquance elle explose l'insécurité
elle explose en 2022 les chiffres c'est
catastrophique et comme l'a dit Delphine
qu'est-ce qu'on fait en fait d'accord
donc tu veux que ce soit quoi le Far
West non pas du tout
je veux juste que je veux juste que ce
soit là c'est la fin du sentiment
d'impunité et je veux qu'on donne des
moyens en policier veux-tu répondre
et je veux que si un problème il y ait
des courses poursuites tu répondras
Géraldine quand une course poursuite se
finira mal globalement et que le
policier normalement il y en a eu pour
les délinquants quand il meurt ou quand
ils sont blessés mais ton tant pis pour
eux
quelqu'un vole ou c'est un truc et que
ça se passe mal une course pour un
mineur sur un scooter qui est
le problème c'est que pas forcément il y
aura des draps c'est une connerie mais
il y a des drames et alors à ce moment
là il faut qu'il s'arrête il faut qu'il
ait peur de la police et en fait
aujourd'hui on n'a pas peur de la police
mais aujourd'hui la police on la
provoque on en a rien à [__] on lui
fait des bras d'honneur on lui crache
dessus et donc moi je veux qu'on ait
peur de la police je veux qu'on flippe
de ces policiers poursuit il y a une
gamine qui est butée
vous allez dans les extrêmes
parce que c'est quoi ça dit quoi votre
truc les délits ça c'est quelqu'un qui a
pas bossé hein
comment on le sait s'il a fait ça ou pas
faut bien le truc donc moi alors on part
du principe que quand tu as raison c'est
drôle ça bah c'est vachement drôle parce
que on le poursuit pas parce qu'il a pas
fait ces délit là mais comment tu le
sais que dangereux comment tu sais qu'il
va parler
il veut pas se soustraire à la police je
vais le chercher lui plus qu'un autre
je vais te chercher
avec une cagoule et je peux me sauver je
m'arrête pas
si je ralentis là comme un con je vais
me faire coffret maintenant on va aller
sur l'autoroute à 190 il a raison
arrêtez à un moment donné ils vont
arrêter la raison il a volé dans un
magasin il va y aller c'est pas là comme
direct comme digérateurdine la police
elle doit être respectée il y a dans tu
vas quand vous a pas chaque fois vous me
parlez dans les autres pays quand tu vas
dans les autres pays la police
souvent vous me dites regardez la raison
passe là-bas
et la police elle fait peur dans
certains pays la police on est vraiment
vraiment dit que vous parlez de la
raison des autres pays sur d'autres cas
voilà sur d'autres sujets en disant mais
moi moi je suis policier tu me dis il y
a une loi qui est sortie tu peux plus
faire de course poursuite quand il y a
un délit à quoi ça sert quelqu'un c'est
comme si tu dis tu peux plus mettre les
menottes pas à quoi ça sert alors faites
ce que vous voulez foutez le bordel
rouler sur les gens et sauvez-vous je
voudrais avoir Bernard Montiel Bernard
Montiel Bernard Montiel
l'autorité de la police
il y a déjà un laxisme incroyable de la
justice
moins que les premiers ceux qui sont sur
le terrain ce sont les policiers il faut
vraiment qu'ils puissent agir comme ils
le sentiment
c'est pas des débiles alors bravo la
police et ben allez-y poursuit encore
une fois ils le peuvent quand il y a un
délit de fuite il le peuvent ils ont le
droit c'est autoriser son cadrer quand
il y a un livre des barrières
en 2023 il y a un peu des caméras
partout je pense pas que ce n'est pas
obligé d'être le Far West dans nos rues
on voit ce que ça donne aux États-Unis
à ton enfant ou à quelqu'un et que le
mec il est en train de se sauver tu dis
à la police
arrêtez arrêtez mais non mais non dans
la circulaire
il faut sortir
la vie de Dany parce que moi Dieu sait
que je ne suis je suis en colère contre
l'impunité et là je pense que souvent le
jeune n'en vaut pas la chandelle et
faire prendre des risques quelqu'un qui
qui marche sur le portable qui attend
son bus les gens font n'importe quoi la
police peut conduire ils ont appris donc
mais je les fuyères peuvent faire
n'importe quoi parce qu'ils ont la
police excusez-moi ça on peut avoir des
drones on peut avoir maintenant des
choses
donc moi je trouve que qu'est-ce qui
pourrait la vie des gens qu'est-ce qui
pourrait la vie les gens quand on quand
tu parles aux gens quand tu parles aux
gens qui habitent dans les quartiers ils
sont honnêtes qui vont travailler tous
les matins qui se lève sans foute le
bordel qu'est-ce qui pourrit la vie
c'est la petite délinquance à deux
balles tu dis aux policiers si tu l'as
l'autre moitié tu ne peux pas le
poursuivre parce que il va tomber avec
sa moto et ça va être toi le coupable tu
ne peux pas faire ça laisse-le faire de
la moto à deux heures du matin et
surtout quand tu l'attrapes dans deux
heures il est dehors non seulement il
faut laisser les policiers non seulement
il faut laisser les policiers travailler
et en plus de ça il faut que derrière le
ministre de la Justice et les lois
condamne les mecs qui pourrissent la vie
de centaines de personnes qui habitent
dans les quartiers parce que les gens se
barrent des quartiers après et après ça
fout le bordel dans les cités pour rien
du tout les citer et ailleurs donc il
faut moi faut donner la les moyens à la
police je vois pas pourquoi tu peux pas
pourquoi tu interdit les courses
poursuites s'il a fait une connerie il
assume on poursuit c'est tout ça sert à
ça
dangereux trop dangereux laissez-le
partir
laissez-le partir qui recommence
ailleurs tout le monde vous vous vivez
pour penser que c'est pas vraiment
pénis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu te fais [__] il faut pas
bouger
[Applaudissements]
parce que si tu bouges tu fais jouir le
mec derrière alors
merci
on va entendre on va entendre le
ministre du passé
le ministre de du laxisme le ministre de
la catastrophe le ministre le ministre
dont va dans le mur
Gilles Verdez le ministre qui veut
protéger les policiers
tout le monde mais tu protèges personne
le ministre des nouvelles technologies
parce que Raymond des nouvelles
technologies avec une coiffure comme ça
plus besoin en plus de course poursuite
les policiers ils ont des moyens
d'identifier ils ont des moyens
d'interpeller ils ont des moyens de
recherche c'est pour ça que cette note
elle est sortie Cyril la course la
course poursuite c'est le temps du passé
justement c'est ça qui est fini
aujourd'hui on identifie on interprète
après et on évite les risques
fais comme si c'était Amandine une fois
tu l'as identifié le mec et que tu vas
pour l'attraper et qui montre ça vu que
tu peux pas le poursuivre parce que
c'est délicieux
là pour l'instant tu fais rien attention
pour toi il y a vraiment des lits de
fuite la je sais pas
des bons gars
et attendre vérifier la circulaire avant
qu'on commence la course poursuite c'est
bon allez course-poursuite
de la sécurité donc les cours de
l'insécurité c'est le Ministre de
l'insécurité urbain et tout ça quoi on
met des drones les drones
je t'adore tu vois pas que tu vis dans
le passé c'est bon on
identifie on repère on arrête voilà
c'est ça la police d'aujourd'hui c'est
pas des courses poursuite où tout le
monde risque il peut y avoir des
victimes sur le bas-côté de la route qui
vont être écrasés
ça un jour être d'accord avec toi 100%
donc avec moi
attends attends t'es d'accord avec toi
je commence à être un peu d'accord
quel connard serait bon
c'est bon
le mec tu es sûr à 100 %
énorme de celui qui qui a fait une
petite bêtise et qui s'arrête
tranquillement qui va prendre une
pénalité qui va prendre une amende
contre celui qui se sauve et qu'on doit
laisser se sauver
si je vous écoute j'ai les motards au
cul parce que j'ai roulé à 120 au lieu
de 115 si je vous écoute je vais rouler
à 200 si je vous écoute mais c'est ça
je suis dans ton corps
on va se retrouver dans un instant je
voudrais savoir ce que pensent les
téléspectateurs tiens ça c'est important
oui 17 % faut-il interdire la course non
à 82 % notre public est souvent d'accord
avec nous merci les chéris merci de de
pas voilà Gilles Verdun